ma sono tutti ragazzi di questo non
video sono per i layer ci siamo
aggiornati su ciò che essa era allora ho
scoperto che c'è un modo per bloccare un
sacco di mappe che pagare quindi ho
comprato l'account premium dj essere
teoricamente mi si dovrebbero sbloccare
un sacco di nove nuovi fatti vedo che
cuoce della roba da tempo famous players
che per un classico teoricamente ci sono
anche le zero i challenge che lui ti
butta nel mezzo e devi cercare di
battere record degli altri tipo chi ha
fatto la daily challenge ha fatto 25
mila punti
oggi proviamo a far di meglio allora
ragazzi sta cosa poi molto importante
perché la gente su sto gioco qua città
in che senso città città perché va su
google e scrive ok vediamo dove siamo ma
io ci sto provando
se senza citare e vedo già subito che
c'è adriano per i che adriano è
diventato conosciuto veramente ovunque
allora ragazzi mi sembra red dead
redemption con una monte grafica no
siamo nel texas dai nel wyoming
siamo nel wyoming wyoming buffalo
company quindi siamo nel wyoming
che bello il wyoming allora wyoming e
questo sono ragazzi senza una scritta
non posso capirlo c'è veramente da te
una scritta madonna osta via quando
l'avete mappata nel 2001 e grafica racca
pizzeria napoletana va bene lo sparo qua
per vedere se chi meno azzeccato la
città poi ovviamente non attacco però
non era il casper era cody porca vacca
come di zack e cody va bene next3 male
però è meno azzeccato che siamo nel
wyoming a questa sì questa ovviamente
milano ma che gli viene in mente di
venire qua qualcosa di google da move
national pinnacle julien bay tensione
qua siamo in america the jury embaye via
cervantes dai almeno quasi come siamo in
una strada sperduta fatemi vedere più o
meno dovette
poi aspetta che la scommessa di american
che questa barca pratica bud cin carrà
siamo più o meno qui cioè più o meno
faccio schifo però 26 km considerando
che l'australia bella grossa non sono
male eh vabbè madonna e allora però
bello questo cesso
se che veramente sembrano sembrare ma
basso da google ma con una grafica da
cartolina degli anni 80 ci sono sia
possibile bell stì copertoni come quelli
di four nights salti vivaista tipi in
alto no era che non lo posso sapere
proprio am america nel mezzo
dio ce la mandi buona
beh dai ragazzi di un po più sul
classico né un su famous places perché
vengo spaces almeno posso far vedere che
sono ignorante normalmente nelle strade
sconosciute quelle vabbè poi anche far
schifo e tanto gli sembrò in queste non
puoi fa schifo allora famous places
questo dovrebbe essere famoso casa mia
non lo so non so neanche dove 03 bello
non so neanche dove siamo ragazzi non so
dice avrà braga
no forse no caffè ristorante pane notre
dame montebello ha inoltre era il retro
limoni notre dame ho capito mettimi
davanti perché nessuno e notre dame de
paris le palle illecite le baguette
tutte le persone allora teorica mount
redoubt pò libero dovrebbe essere tipo
qua
qui perché eravamo tipo su questa via 9
scusami qua probabile credo
praticamente qui più o meno porca vacca
di 69 metri va bene next a questa qua
catania comunque mi piace che ho scelto
famo posti famosi nel mondo ci sono un
sacco di roba mia in tutto parigi
abbiamo la torre psi però non mi puoi
dire che la strada ma che ne so la
strada sarà questa qua dietro mi pare
dalla parte dell'autobus quindi q a 5
metri
tutto qui bene spot on
eravamo lì esattamente lo perde il punto
preciso mi è capitato poche volte ho
capito grazie al parco minchio piacenza
comunque devo capire un attimo dove
perché allora il problema il problema di
ogni volta che mi mette geogrà dentro
venezia e non so cosa fare perché non
come faccio a capire dove che ne so
faremo space e ho capito venezia però
non è che questa questo canale
quindi un attimo che un casinò venezia
tu che ami venezia c'è nel senso per me
ve ne sei crediti orlo di ogni modello
caso gayser lo dico sempre per me
venezia incredibile è tipo da perché
allora il discorso è questo secondo me
gli stranieri credono che noi siamo
abituati alla bellezza di venezia dicono
mamma mia da venezia come una favola in
italiano per gli italiani sarà normale
però per noi che viviamo all'estero è
una favola no anche per noi italiani è
una favola venezia per me venezia nipote
la vedo di come madonna ma ce l'abbiamo
veramente noi venezia è veramente troppo
pedro quindi a me piace io sono
innamorato di star città non solo anche
lui guarda però non so come mai ce l'ho
sempre avuta io questa cosa qua di
venezia incredibile un canale a caso
vediamo questo no palacio marcello
marcello matese due sì che non mi fa né
anche madonna viva il taj mahal
grazie a dio meno male perché non mi
faceva neanche muovere quindi non potevo
neanche andare in giro a capire che cosa
era meno male che ti ho riconosciuto lo
stesso perché persone che studiano o no
cos'è il monte rushmore senza anche
unitario monte rushmore lo sapevo ma lo
sapevo ma in tutto qui ciò non l'ho
neanche visto dall asp dalla stradina
c'è ma tu puoi azzeccare dalla stradina
un momento incredibile non ci sono mai
stato madonna bene va bene comunque io
da questa strada ho riconosciuto il
monte rushmore lo stomaco un gran porco
demonio noi eravamo lì kieft shop
vabbè dai un chilometro parco demonio
24.000 punti
incredibile solo perché i primi due run
parigi sono lo sapevo lavello next sono
stato molto bravo è figura che questa è
l'arco questo lo riceve al parco
sempione milano ragazze alla partitica
il senso vediamo di chiudere sempre con
l'italia perchè l'italia le mani tese
magnifique però che l'ho detto in
francese
abbiamo italy 2.0 che nuova vediamo
ragazzi non lo so vediamo come si è
ammessi e che quest'anno a far generata
da poco
allora qui siamo sicuro non è milano
siamo la falesia è comune di ventotene
ventotene ventotene moderare la velocità
tensione i pedoni ventotene
non ho idea di dove sia avvenuto ten e
salve o aimi madonna era un'isola
faticava a cardiff e sarà più difficile
da capo nord che sarà veramente
difficile
questa bike macbook secondo me neanche
gli italiani sanno che esiste non so
ragazzi mi spacco
nulla qua sto sparando non era lì però
va a 500 metri da una parte all'altra
dell'isola 500 metri va bene si vabbè ma
potevi scegliermi un po più difficili
magari che ne so
dai ragazzi ma che ne so io non ho idea
di dove sia questo posto ragazzi ma non
potrei mettermi in centro milano per
favore o san marino san marino il centro
storico e monte titano patrimonio
dell'umanità quindi siamo però non siamo
in italia uguale attenzione facciamo i
seri non siamo in italia siamo in via
petrino di cinzia non siamo comunque in
italia rialziamo a san marino che
dovrebbe stare a fare un caso me ne
sbatto 6 km porca vacca era più facile
l'isola va bene questo qua bella service
questa uscita al dark souls st chiesa
dunque ragazzi non ho idea però so che
dai graffiti troverò qualcosa allora
prima cosa che noto è a qualche straten
si è cancellato un po kiss stramo non è
che ti ha non ti amo ti stramo c'è poco
ti stramo ed di strangolo abbia
sbagliato a scrivere ragazzi in mente ci
possiamo problemi e b 0 0
sì mi sembra un posto di mare la ragazza
la classica collinetta prime aree eccolo
lì parte signora tutto a posto come
bellissimo vestito
mi scusi dov'è che siamo qua se non
capisco come come a suo agio la signora
guardare google maps napoli salerno
forti c a napoli allora aspettavamo che
capisco napoli napoli napoli non vedo
napoli portici portici portici tu al
napoli napoli napoli salerno 15 alla
napoli salerno lì quindi qua siamo
vicini a napoli saremo
che ne so ma che ne so portici ercolano
madonna madonna proprio lui duck marcava
cacio andato mi stato troppo poco
pesante con la collinetta invece qua
come monio va bene ma le ragazzine che è
stata un'ottima giocata sono molto
soddisfatto perché bisogna andare molto
peggio se dovesse vincere però ti
ringrazio per aver seguito il video però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi lasciato mi
piace un bacino
iscrivetevi al canale campanellina e noi
come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
video della rai a
[Musica]